ich wünsche mir dass die deutsche
politik klar sagt wie sie uns helfen
können
ich möchte von herrn scholz gerne
konkrete hören wie in meinem land und
mir helfen kann
je härter die sanktionen sind und je
stärker der druck von außen kommt desto
schneller gibt es ein ende für
lukaschenko in minsk ist für uns bild
vize paul ronzheimer paul du warst auch
wer alexej wie geht es die mittlerweile
man sieht immer noch schnell wieder
verhaftet wurden apropos habt ich stehe
hier und dem gefängnis wo auch der
ehemann der oppositionsführerin die in
litauen fest jetzt hier es gehalten wird
und die menschen sind gekommen bei der
heute geburtstag hat aber ihre hinter
mir hinter diesen mauern in diesem
gefängnis einsitzt gibt es denn
irgendwelche verlässlichen zahlen die
wir sagen wie viele menschen momentan in
gefängnissen sitzen weil sie eben auf
den demonstrationen festgenommen worden
sind nein es gibt keine verletzten
das ist 1000 freigelassen aber die
wichtigen wie zum beispiel der ehemann
der oppositionsführerin sitzen weiter
fest und man sieht hier neben dem
bereitstehen
die immer wieder brüllen lasst ihn frei
und das besondere an diesem gefängnis
ist es
wenn man sie ausgehen dass wir gegen den
bauern also wir machen mit man darauf
konzentriert mit ihrem protest schon
etwas von alexei gehört was wünschen
sich die menschen aus weiß was man jetzt
von deutschland von der eu generell von
der welt wie kann man ihnen helfen wenn
man mit den menschen spricht dann haben
sie interessanterweise das mit was olaf
scholz der pc kann es dabei bild live
gesagt hat diese zitate von olaf scholz
sind um die welt gegangen sie wurden
auch ihrem ins zitiert sie wurden in der
new york times zitiert und das hat viele
überrascht denn woher haben sie klarheit
nicht gut gemacht und zumindest ein
bisschen aber es ist so wie alexei sagt
die hoffen dass deutschland dann auch
konkret etwas tun kann vielleicht morgen
aber auch der schweizer gebracht wir
dürfen vor allem das weiterhin geschaut
wird was hier auf den straßen passiert
denn natürlich ist die angst da dass
lukas schenk und noch einmal
zurückschlagen könnte mit massiver
gewalt